[Aplausos]
você em algum momento da sua vida já
pensam ele para outro planeta ou até
mesmo construir algo lá estamos sempre
batalhando para que isso aconteça sem
que estas tenham distribuídas nos
planetas estão sempre evoluindo vamos
usar mais como exemplo o clima lá é
totalmente diferente
a vida lá com certeza será diferente a
radiação é muito maior e como iríamos
respirar
existem muitas coisas para serem
respondidas por dia por exemplo serão
daria para construir mais casas lá em
casa são conhecimento mas como se nesse
momento eo que poderíamos fazer em marte
onde de avaliação é muito maior o que
pode acabar causando câncer foi muito
nisto que usaram de cimento para a
posição de indústrias e edifícios e
principalmente casas para diminuição
radiação recebida mas enviasse o cimento
utilizado aqui na terra ele sofreria
mudanças no processo de crescimento para
esse precisamos saber se ele vai crescer
eu espero que isso não demora muito
tempo até porque eu me candidatarei para
ser um dos moradores de martin foi
pensando nisso que um grupo de alunos de
escolas diferentes realidades se
juntaram para ajudar os cientistas
foi pensando nisso que a gente teve a
idéia de fazer esse projeto
alguns cientistas já tinham pesquisado
sobre o conhecimento reagiu no espaço
eles descobriram que lá o cimento ficar
durinha por fora e oco por dentro e não
da promoção de uma casa assim
então a gente pensou em usar o plástico
verde que é um plástico feito a partir
do bagaço da cana de açúcar ea gente
pensa em fazer uma estrutura e colocar
dentro do cimento e se formar um bloco
ajuste o espaço de um tubo para fazer
esse experimento então a gente separou
em três partes
nas laterais a gente colocou água e na
parte central a gente colocou essa
estrutura de plástico verde que separou
as duas pequenas partes
em uma delas a gente colocou cimento uma
areia muito parecida com a dela na área
e alguns flocos do plástico
já na outra a gente colocou o sol
cimento e areia lunar
a gente fez dois experimentos um choque
na terra e outro foi lá o espaço para
quando o espaço voltará a gente tem como
comparar os resultados
a gente descobriu que o cimento material
que essa sujeira fica quente se poderia
vir a ter essa tube caso algum problema
para os astronautas não é isso que a
gente queria e nem a nasa permitiria
então a gente pesquisou e pequenas
proporções que seria no caso não teria
nenhum problema
então é eu o natan a sofia e mais dois
meninos que não estou aqui hoje o
guilherme othon
a gente se reuniu várias vezes e laboral
melhor experimento possível e como
sophia já falou a gente fez tudo o
controle e o que envolve o espaço dia 28
de junho deste ano como mostra o vídeo a
seguir lançamento do foguete em que ele
estava
ae
tó
op
i liga
mas é legal capitais isso resolve
[Aplausos]
acreditar
nessa reta final quem aconselhasse a
qualquer preço que em casa do pacote
office é preciso escolher a aliança
óbvia
a obra
a festa é na verdade a xuxa
rafael o resto é chutar
eu vou tocar a terra mas a gente acabou
de ter acesso ainda a gente não
conseguiu nenhum resultado e agora a
gente quer fazer todos os testes
necessários para ver cimento endurece
endurecer de uma forma pelo menos
parecida com a que na terra e se ele do
que a radiação seja realmente funcionar
no futuro a gente até ajudar ao sentir
que estão há tanto tempo escrevendo como
a gente pode sobreviver em outro planeta
e quem sabe a gente até consiga
construir caso vá e aí quem já que a
encomenda é sua
[Aplausos]